of all of the ways to die Hunter Hunter
has some of the absolute worst reading
the series is often like walking through
a beautiful Lush landscape absolutely
littered with deep dark person-sized
holes that one can fall into at any
given moment without warning tagashi has
used Hunter Hunter to explore the very
depths of human Darkness not only by
inserting actual real world atrocities
into the series but Togashi himself has
become quite Adept at inventing his own
exceptionally gruesome ways to die there
are some times in this series where I
feel like I'm watching some sort of ser
real killer documentary instead of a
Shonen series and that leaves me with
one big question who had the worst death
in all of Hunter Hunter well stop one on
our death Discovery train is any victim
of nanika known more technically as the
Dark Continent Calamity eye those who
fall victim to its powers are squashed
and twisted until a state of death has
been achieved and done so with such
force that it leaves human bodies
looking like wet towels after a
particularly bloody shower I would say
that Nika's numerous victims are easily
the most visceral deaths in the series
but there is a Saving Grace for the
victims which is that death is pretty
much instantaneous so the true horror of
this experience is felt more so by those
who discover the remains many of which
are kept in a super secret facility that
studies various Dark Continent related
phenomena and in particular victims of
eye are described as quote things that
used to be human there is a potential
bonus element of horror here that might
completely flip my perspective though
which is that these remains are kept in
sort of stasis tubes offering up the
potential that maybe the victims are
some still alive in these tubes
thankfully that is mercifully unlikely
because the zics do specifically refer
to Nan's victims as being dead and
honestly Lucky them because there is a
whole laundry list laundry is a pun
because nanica brings victims like a
towel there is a whole laundry list of
worst ways to go out in Hunter Hunter
one of which would be having the
unfortunate fate of crossing paths with
the Phantom troops fatan because as
adorable funny and often Flatout cool as
he is fatan is one of the people that I
would never want to run into in any
world fatan genuinely enjoys inflicting
pain on others probably learned from the
hundreds and thousands of hours of snuff
films that he would have watched whilst
attempting to find sasa's murder tape
and he takes a very clinical approach to
his work a sort of torture Min Maxa
Fan's goal is to keep a person alive as
long as possible so for example when
Nobunaga was potentially about to break
gon's arm fatan interjected he said no
Nobunaga no before you break the arm you
first break the fingers and before you
break the fingers you first extract the
fingernails with this in mind I
ultimately feel incredibly sorry for the
York new Auctioneer because even uen
said that fatan worked him over good and
by the end of the process even fatan
himself felt sorry for his victim we
don't know the specifics and in many
ways that makes it worse because the
imagination is Limitless and this may
well be one of the most painful ways to
die in the series but even if that is
the case I'm far from sure that this is
the worst way also this fictional Hunter
content is sponsored by by pocket Champs
a spectacularly vibrant and fun
free-to-play game on Android or iOS
where you get the opportunity to coach
your champ and unlock its true potential
it's like Rocky with adorable characters
actually Rocky isn't a very modern
reference anymore it's like Creed with
adorable characters and so it's up to
you to strategize and discover the best
race strategy and after that like any
good trainer you trust your champ to win
sit back and watch as glor is deliver
directly to your doorstep along with
memorable characters a ton of
Collectibles consistent new content the
thing I love most most about this game
is the rich vibrant universe as a
longtime shown a manga fan this Sleek
simple and just playing Fun World really
appeals to me also I've partnered with
pocket Champs to offer you guys a stup
pack with 500 gems plus a white wolf
skin just click the link in the
description or scan the QR code to
download Pocket Champs and these rewards
will be automatically added to your
account on November 1st 2023 so
genuinely thank you so much to pocket
champs for sponsoring this video in
doing so they are directly supporting my
ability to pay my fantastic artists and
channel editors but above all again it's
just a really fun game so go download it
but for now it's back to you me to
contrast this we have the intrinsically
terrifying indoor fish a nen ability
categorically designed for painless
torture now you might be thinking that
doesn't make sense the purpose of
torture is to inflict pain well not
necessarily and I guess think of it this
way Fan's process is designed to extract
information and increasing pain is the
tool which he uses to achieve that
meanwhile the user of indoor fish wants
nothing except the suffering of their
target these are n Beast that can only
exist in closed rooms they are
carnivorous fish who dine exclusively on
human flesh and whilst being devoured
the victims do not bleed nor do they
feel any pain whatsoever and I that I
don't know man watching your body being
gradually eaten perfectly aware of
what's Happening sounds like a whole new
level of existential horror less
physical pain but significantly more
terror and the victim is essentially
Immortal until the indoor fish are
deactivated at which point the victim is
finally permitted to die so in theory
you could keep someone in this state for
as long as you yourself are willing to
remain in the closed room but torture
isn't exclusively a human device the
Kera ants yunju and mosquito had a
particularly disturbing hobby of keeping
a series of human pets said pets were
collared forced to be naked and even
taught to walk on their elbows
legitimately one of the most disturbing
things I've seen in Hunter Hunter
potentially meteor in general because
one of those quote pets was so
psychologically broken that by the end
of it he believed he was a dog in this
case the most merciful aspect of the
process was the actual death which was a
quick stomp on the head but it's more so
everything leading up to that which
cements this as one of the most
unpleasant Fates in the series with
Chimera ants in particular though we can
definitely do one better and all I need
to do is say one word pockle this is
when Hunter Hunter absolutely flawed me
the moment where this series switched
from a Shonen with a bit of a streak of
Darkness into fullon body horror and
it's not just about how pockle died but
the events leading up to to it P was
able to survive the initial poisoning by
zazon quite luckily due to a hidden
antidote however I dare say that this
was the unluckiest thing that could have
possibly happened because eventually
pacle found himself in a desperate
situation where he was hiding within a
mountain of remains deep deep within the
Chimera anair I really can't imagine
what was going through his mind in these
last moments but the word hopeless comes
to mind just as pole was swiftly
discovered and Pito came to his mind
quite literally as Pito lobotomized to
find out everything he knew about nen he
was also stripped naked and you might be
wondering why that seems a bit
unnecessary well it wasn't actually and
it was in preparation for Pole's finale
this was considered too brutal to be
shown in the anime but in the manga
after Pito is finished pockle is
immediately butchered by Pig and fed to
the ant Queen so stripping pockle was
the equivalent of preparing one's food
by removing the packaging it's unknown
exactly how much of this pocka was
consciously aware of or felt it could be
some it could be all it could be none
but regardless this is easily one of the
most undesirable deaths in a series full
of exceptionally brutal ways to die but
even then honestly the Chimera ants are
far from the worst in fact this next
death doesn't even come from a n user at
the commencement of York New City kopa
entered a building known as the flesh
collector's mansion and this is our
first real introduction to body partk
collecting a truly gruesome hobby that
only the wealthiest people in this world
have the means and lack of humanity to
participate the flesh collector himself
is light nrad and the most memorable
piece in his collection is the man in
the painting a former bodyguard who put
the family in danger and as punishment
was turned into a one-of-a-kind
collector's piece hung within the
mansion's walls as a warning for all
other the bodyguards so the thing that
really gets me about this is how well
Togashi portrays the look of sheer
Terror on his face as well as the
contorted body like you can see that he
was struggling to get free right up to
the very second that he was covet in
well he was coved in whatever ever it is
resin maybe but again this is another
one of those methods which isn't the
most painful but certainly is one of the
more terror inducing and all for the
sake of art although light NRA does have
a contemporary artist that puts even his
work to shame fourth Prince of the Coan
Empire sidik has dedicated his life to
the pursuit of art however his art is
about more than just the final product
it's about the process and the materials
the materials being people and the
process being about as morbid of a death
as you can imagine and in fact Serina
himself describes it as follows if I'm
skinning pigs and monkeys it's just
dissection what I seek is Art produced
by youth with the future put in an
extreme situation A synthesis of the
Arts so in regular language what snik
aims to do is take people with Bright
Futures and then take that future away
from them whilst they're fully aware and
in the most extreme situation that sidet
can conjure and rather unfortunately
sik's imagination is practically
Limitless he is a true genius in every
sense of the word but a Sinister genius
who is never short on inspiration for
new works and in fact he's one of only
two characters in the series who have
been described as pure evil afterwards
snik has the remains constructed into
the final pieces often tattooed and
framed by his collaborating artist the
scariest thing is that this is what sik
was doing prior to learning nen there
are no magical powers involved
whatsoever in what's happening here this
horror was all the result of pure
realistic human desire interestingly
sik's tattoo artist may be connected to
our next and potentially ultimately
unpleasant way to die which is sasa's
murder because sidik artist Bears a
strong resemblance to one of the child
snatchers spotted in meteor City and
after going through all of these I'm not
going to lie I'm starting to feel a bit
desensitized to death in Hunter Hunter
but even then this incident hits me hard
there have been victims in this video
who have undergone horrific deaths but
knew the risks of their actions like
pockle this is just the sort of thing
that may happen when you're a licensed
Hunter all people who were Insidious
figures themselves and likely
responsible for inflicting their own
fair share of Horrors but sarasa was a
completely innocent child an innocent
child murdered for the sake of
entertainment this process was
videotaped and her remains were left on
display as a show for those who found
them so we have yet another case of I
guess creativity here but this time in
the realm of film there was no purpose
to this Beyond pushing the bounds of
human cruelty all for the satisfaction
of others what happened to sarasa was so
shocking that her remains and the note
left by The Killers were kept out of
sight from the rest of the Phantom troop
although there is some respite because
her body was put back together and
embalmed by a n user named Reno and you
know in contrast to a lot of these
deaths one of the saddest deaths in the
series and King maram looks simply
Blissful in comparison imagine just
being able to slowly slip away into
Eternal sleep with the person you love
most by your side imagine that and then
let's compare it to the absolute worst
way to die in Hunter Hunter this is the
CTA Clan Massacre and I guarantee that
the fate of this poor poor Clan is an
order of magnitude worse than you
probably remember what most of you will
remember is that the clan were Massac
and the scared eyes harvested from those
who possessed them and that's that's
already pretty bad to be honest but
Togashi decided that he really needed to
hammer this one home in volume zero we
have a two chapter prequel to Hunter
Hunter following keka's backstory up
until the moment of the Massac and
whilst Togashi doesn't show what happens
for reasons that will become apparent he
does go into some pretty extraordinary
written detail family members were sat
down facing each other they were stabbed
multiple times and had their heads
severed while still alive pure Kurt clan
members had both eyes gouged out the
eyes of Outsiders who married into the
clan remained but were squashed they had
sustained more brutal wounds than other
members of the clan it is also believed
that the perpetrators mutilated the
children more frequently and brutally in
front of their parents in order to
produce a more Vivid scarlet color a
message believed to be from the
perpetrators was found near the slain
bodies we'll accept anything you leave
but don't ever take anything away from
us and that's just kind of the world
Hunter Hunter is even though this
massacre was mostly a business decision
that business emphasized inflicting
maximum cruelty for maximum reward and
even though I do personally think this
would be the most horrific and
undesirable way to die I can definitely
see arguments being made for any method
mentioned in this video so let me know
in the comments what do you think is the
worst way to die in Hunter Hunter and
thanks again to pocket for sponsoring
this video and you can download the game
through the link in the description